we were talking about this a little bit
before the show Elon Musk or I think
even during the show and I hung out at a
party with a bunch of people in Elon
Musk Circle and they all believe that
technology is the solution of the
culture war and I'm like that's like
saying if we're going to win this War I
need to buy a lot of land because
everybody knows whoever controls the
land wins the war so by owning the land
it's like okay dude they're gonna walk
onto your lane with guns because you
have no people on the land exactly the
challenge is getting the land and people
on the land so they're not they're not
fully there they're buying the land
isn't going to give you the battlefield
but that's that's how they feel so to a
certain extent it obviously does benefit
you know like Elon Musk buying Twitter
did a lot of really important things but
they genuinely the all these guys are
like yeah once we control Tech then
we're gonna it's like maybe a little bit
Yeah like you can increase awareness and
I look at it like if anybody plays the
Starcraft type of games you can increase
your land mass like Tim's talking about
but you need to have people on it for it
to really mean something to be able to
protect it so I think that helps but
that's not the full full answer Elon
Musk is great in the area of business
and engineering and all that when it
comes to the solutions to these issues I
think he's an infant I think morally
he's struggling we were talking about
the Twitter files releases
is anybody watching the Twitter file
anybody reading those I'm reading them
but no it's not reaching anybody and I
think he's struggling look man
you know people get people got mad
because I was you know Luke and I were
eating dinner and I see that one of the
Twitter file stories comes out Saturday
at like 6 p.m and then I was like are
you nuts dude not only is it a Saturday
when traffic is at an all-time low for
the week but it's dinner time on
Saturday I mean like Saturday mornings
and maybe people are waking up and they
might check their phone Friday evening
is is rough because everyone's leaving
work and going to the bar Saturday
afternoon you're done and I'm like did
they intentionally kill this story by
doing so now they were they keep doing
the stupid thing where they're like you
go to slow roll the stories you gotta
like with with the with the um Snowden
Stuff Glenn Greenwald and poitress
they're like I don't know whose idea it
was but they were like slowly release
the stories to maximize reach and I'm
like no what happens is you put out
mediocre story mediocre story mediocre
story we're done we're tired not
interested
with the Twitter files they should have
released like 10 stories all at once
they should have put the files in a
repository and released them and let the
entire Community have access
instead I guess Twitter files came out
this morning nope nobody tweeted it
nobody shared it are you serious
15 the last one I saw was 14. oh yeah
yeah it was uh lee Fang oh my God yeah
he started the Twitter files thread uh
10 hours ago wow so they should have
just dropped all the files all at once
like Wikileaks yeah if I had access to
the Twitter files and I released them
like how Elon did like everybody would
be destroying me right they'd be like
what are you doing like who cares are
you releasing them on a Saturday this is
a big story too this is about um the
pharmaceutical industry lobbying big
Tech to ban people who are anti-vaxx wow
or not even are calling for cheaper
medicines right yeah and so uh this this
dropped
from the Twitter files and uh nobody
talked about it
here's what should have happened he
should have dumped all Communications
because the other issue is Elon Musk is
hoping these journalists can find the
stories
big mistake yeah and that baby's
fantastic
but
there's probably something in the
Twitter files I'll give you an example
if I was talking to somebody
and said
you know let's say the email says
something like this
hey this is uh Tim from over at timcast
I was wondering if you can give me uh an
update on the Natalie foot frontside
Cricket grind we're looking at John uh
hitting those slappies and we wanted to
get something a bit more substantive so
we needed maybe like uh you know big
heel back tail big big flip out
Matt Toby's gonna look at that email and
be like I have no idea what this says
and he's gonna ignore it
now anybody who skates is going to be
like they're filming Escape video those
are some sick tricks a big heel back
tail that's crazy like we're talking
about big inward heal man we're not
talking about front side but my point is
jargon esoteric language someone might
say something like an acronym one of the
pharmaceutical guys might be like yo
we've gotta we've got a jn3 uh you know
out of our backlog files and this is
this is pretty serious and he's going to
be like I don't know what that is and
then somebody who knows security might
mean this was a Russian hacker who broke
in and stole people's medical files or
something who knows if Elon were to take
all the emails and just dump them out
and be like
there you go everybody you'd have
decentralized investigation right you'd
have people in the medical industry
being like whoa whoa whoa look at this
instead what you get are journalists who
are not experts in any of this
trying to find the social sounding
stories to publish hey look
pharmaceutical companies lobbied to ban
content okay I'm not surprised by that
but what about the pharmaceutical
companies talking in emails with other
Executives about
how adverse effects monetary policy
pertaining to the vaccines things that a
Layman could not understand
the journalists are taking a political
angle how were they colluding with each
other
a person who's into medical or
pharmaceutical might be like how were
they preparing to sell this and what
were they saying about the the rn6 codes
you know so I'm making it up but let's
say like there's an FDA Administrative
Code that gets released with every
product these journals won't even know
what to look for
instead we get limited access put out on
terrible times and nobody even knows
what's happening we need 4chan to to
have the files now no actually not even
a joke
I'm going to take it a little further I
think the Twitter files are a psyop this
is Elon Musk is not he's I mean he might
be kind of a novice in a way with the
media side of stuff but he's not stupid
and we know there's still FBI and CIA X
you know you know agents are there at
Twitter right now
um Dr Shiva arude
said that Elon Musk was asked point
blank is the portal still open between
the government and Twitter and he said
I'll look into it
so it's to me and then Jim Baker you
probably remember that Jim Baker was
filtering the files when you look at all
the Twitter files at the end of each
thread
they say we didn't do the searching some
a Twitter lawyer did the search they're
not even able to search through the data
it to me you add all of it up it's
almost like
Elon and this is complete speculation
this is play in chess Elon remember he
was held up on the deal for a while in
in court before he said okay I'm gonna
buy it
what if Elon was like I I gotta buy it
but I want people to trust me
so let me go ahead I gotta release some
information for people to buy into me so
you release some information you release
it on odd hours you slow roll it now
nobody I didn't even know I've been
following this stuff I didn't even know
it was released so now you've built some
trust with the radical people who are
paying attention there's no Normie
around Thanksgiving I think it was or or
Christmas I was asking normies anytime I
saw Normie that you know we're just
chilling somewhere I was like have you
ever heard of the Twitter files
not one person told me they knew
anything I was like what do you think of
Elon Musk they're like I hate him like
why do you they don't even know him it's
a psyop to in my opinion affect those
who are paying attention
to gain trust and
um to buy in and elon's I think it's
paying off how many people do you see on
the right you know kind of bigging him
up and I I think Elon Musk has been a
fraud so far it could change but when it
comes to his first amendment stance and
the Twitter files this is a debacle and
uh to add to your point maybe that's why
the stories get released on Friday and
Saturday nights to make sure they don't
actually have any real press impact Elon
that's the pr 101 yeah the questions out
there Elon tell us why they're released
at this time why haven't you released
all the files now why are the lawyers
doing the searching well it could be to
try to bring people in for when traffic
is low on Twitter in order to build up
advertisers I mean and then let's be
honest here I think Elon Musk lost uh
more money than anyone else in recorded
history
on this particular deal and he he you
know lost a lot he waited a lot too what
he's doing with it is he going to be
doing the hive mind is he going to be
doing the X app the everything WhatsApp
WeChat app I mean time will only tell
I'm still waiting for the fauci files
and then I'm gonna make my decision
after that to to discern what is going
on here but so far hey we did get a lot
of crazy information especially about
the FBI essentially running Twitter
essentially running social media and
deciding who has a voice and not that's
huge having those receipts I mean that's
big right there so what's happening
behind the scenes I don't know but uh I
want to give him a little bit more of
the benefit of the doubt myself I felt
like the it was very cringe the way
things happened and I'm going to be
really critical about it calling it the
Twitter files it's like we're a little
group look how cool we are what's the
name that you would give him you don't
need to name it yes release the data
yeah what the hell I agree and then it
gives it to like particular journalists
they're like I'm the one with the power
now and you're like I can't stand it
always hated it what also prevents
connecting the dots because if the
general public had it we could connect
the dots between this person and that
person this document but when you have
it in in so many separate hands it's
it's very hard to get the bigger kind of
story here or even the whole truth here
yeah it's almost almost like um I do
want to give Elon credit because I think
the information is true and I think it's
good but imagine if you have the j6
footage and I can't search through it I
have to ask your lawyer to search
through it we want all the footage and
just let us search through it how we
want thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time